this is the High School class of 1980.
this is the class of 2000 and this is
the class of 2020. notice anything
different between these two images look
at the men now look at the picture from
the class of 2020. you don't see men do
you those are boys aren't they are you a
man who feels like you're losing your
age are you getting all you can from
your workouts are you satisfied with
your romantic life researchers have
found that male sperm count has
plummeted by 50 since the 1970s rectal
dysfunction social anxiety low
confidence fear of talking to women
obesity low sperm counts difficulty
building muscle depression and lack of
motivation they're all problems Modern
Men are facing more than any generation
ever before I kept feeling worse and
worse I had no energy at all and no sex
drive either but I could feel something
just wasn't right it didn't happen
overnight and then I was diagnosed with
depression and I realized that something
was seriously wrong with me and then I
figured out that this might have
something to do with the testosterone
deficiency they are all associated with
lower testosterone level
[Applause]
[Music]
it said testosterone is the hormone that
makes men well men
it sculpts the male body increasing
muscle mass and Bone strength and molds
the male mind fueling libido wrist touch
and the pursuit of status since 1950 the
testosterone level in men have been
dropping up to one percent a year in
some context the average 30 year old guy
today would have the same testosterone
levels as a guy who was 60 years old in
1950. so what's causing such a rapid
decrease in testosterone soy does it
feminize you doesn't give you man boobs
does it lower testosterone there's even
like residual estrogen in our tap water
because of birth control the massive
influence of estradiol from the birth
control pill which leaks into the water
table and does not get filtered out
through Municipal Water Supplies tap
water contains things like endocrine
disruptors hormone disruptors that can
negatively impact reproductive Health in
males and the Advent of bpas and
Plastics drinking and eating and
touching a lot of these materials which
leaks through our skin get into our
bodies and act as estrogen mimicking
compounds the amount of testosterone in
your body may be equivalent to a pinch
of sugar in an Olympic swimming pool and
yet it has these profound effects
However the fact remains that men are
becoming less of well men not only in
their behavior and in their dress but
also in their biological makeup men now
are weaker slower and less intelligent
we are simply put not the men our
fathers are
humanity is facing a crisis right now
men are getting weaker and softer both
mentally and physically and it's all
because of one thing testosterone we're
all getting old low testosterone low
testosterone testosterone levels
testosterone
sex drive be the best you can be today
men are experiencing a population level
decline in testosterone levels and it's
happening to all men including
Adolescent and young adult men and why
is this collapsed and testosterone bad
because testosterone is what makes men
men
testosterone is a very important male
hormone if a man doesn't have any
testosterone he loses a lot of
characteristics that makes him a man I
mean it's the male super hormone right
it's the thing that drives us towards
success it's the thing that influences
motivation energy levels and as men's
testosterone drops they get pudgy they
lack motivation guys get man boobs like
it is the key hormone for men being men
testosterone is what gives us ambition
Drive is what pushes us to achieve to
win to dominate it's what gives us our
masculine features to take away a man
testosterone is to take away everything
that makes him a man and yet that is
what modern society is systematically
doing to you right now and it's not even
just testosterone between the years 1973
and 2011 male sperm count dropped by 59
we have less than half the sperm count
from just 50 years ago and based on
predictions sperm count will reach Zero
by 2045 but there's lots of kids on
there and like the bodybuilding
communities who are in their early early
late teens early Twenties that are a lot
of them even some not but some getting
their blood work done beforehand and
having abysmal testosterone levels
they're talking about how their
testosterones are in like the one to two
hundreds nanograms per deciliter which
is on the like the very very bottom of
the scale and these guys getting on
testosterone because it's like what's
the trade-off like do I start
testosterone therapy and feel great feel
like a normal person and be able to go
to the gym and feel it be healthy and
sacrifice not being able to have kids
like it's a very heated sort of topic
because there's an obvious trade-off to
doing that but there's a huge advantage
to doing it too because you feel so good
when people feel so good when they do it
or in other words if you don't do
something about this if you don't learn
what's causing this drop in testosterone
and sperm count the survival of the
human race is legitimately a Staker so
in this video we're gonna go over all
the different things in our modern world
that are attacking your testosterone
right now along with what you can do
about it and as you see this list is
very very long over the last several
years the U.S Geological Survey has
tested the water it found that something
in the water is tampering with the
hormones of 85 percent of the male
smallmouth bass and a quarter of the
male largemouth bass and causing them to
develop female reproductive traits
actually scientists call it male
feminization I mean it's literally
termed male feminization if you expose
animals to enough of these chemicals you
can turn a male frog into a female or a
male animal into a female and all this
kind of thing stay dangerous and this is
the downfall of men
foreign
[Music]
was first brought into the U.S in 1804
American Dairy Farmers went crazy for it
this simple little bean was super cheap
and super high in protein which made it
great for feeding cows but Soy also
contains something else extremely high
levels of estrogen if you don't know
estrogen is the females what
testosterone is to males estrogen is
what makes women women but when estrogen
levels become too high especially in
males it can lead to a whole lot of
problems like infertility low
testosterone slow growth shrinking
muscle mass and weight gain and so it
happens to have more estrogen than any
other Bean in existence now seriously
one cup of soybeans has the equivalent
amount of estrogen as 20 000 cups of
chickpeas which made soy the perfect
food for Farmers to fatten up their cows
thanks to the high estrogen contents
American farmers could feed their cow
soy in the estrogen would make cows
super super super fat and the fat they
got the more money the farmer stood to
make and sure it probably wasn't great
that these farmers were Force feeding
estrogen to their cows and therefore
forced us estrogen through the meat and
milk but who cares the cows were now
bigger and juicier than ever so no one
complained soy became a miracle crop for
the American Meat industry but Soy also
became great for the food industry as a
whole here was the super cheap protein
alternative that could be molted into
anything your heart desired and so soy
flourished amongst big food food
companies all over the U.S started to
create their own cheap soy food
derivatives things like soybean oil soy
protein isolate and soy flour were
quickly seeping into the American food
supply Lay's chips could be fried in a
blend of cheap canola corn and soy oil
Campbell's chicken noodle soup will get
a dash of soy protein isolates and IMS
dog food would get soybean meal and
before you know it soy started to be
found in so many different foods some
Americans were switching from beef
burgers to Soy Burgers french fries were
fried in soy oil and soy based formula
was getting fed to babies but little did
these soy guzzlers know that eating all
this estrogen on a daily basis would
lead to some unexpected consequences
it's interesting because all all
scientists agree that soy acts like
estrogen even the vegan scientists like
that are defending it and stuff they say
of course it acts like estrogen but it's
not just the actual soybean that was now
killing testosterone it's also what grew
on soy see after soy is harvested it's
usually stored for months and months and
months in dingy storehouses and what
happens when you store food products for
months and months and months in dingy
storehouses mode will start to grow on
the beans that's right the same mode
that you find in a dark damp basement is
floating in your cup of soy milk and
guess what that mold is also highly
estrogenic they analyzed serum
mycoestrogen that's estrogen secreted by
molds found in grains we're going to
talk about that and they looked at 30
girls with early puberty 30 girls that
were healthy and they found high levels
of mold estrogen in the girls with early
puberty what else did they find though
more interestingly they found the girls
were bigger they fatter they had more
weight this mold estrogen has a chemical
resemblance to anabolic agents used in
animal breeding and there's other papers
that say the same thing they talk about
how Farm Farmers used to use this
specifically to fatten cows maybe they
still do but they actually would inject
it and use it as a drug mold estrogen it
makes the animals fatter makes the girls
fatter too that's right all those bad
side effects you get from eating too
much soy well it's doubly bad if the soy
has mold on it so all these high
estrogen food products that become the
norm in society are just silently
crushing your testosterone and causing
you to have all these bad side effects
so if you haven't already it's time to
cut all this artificial food out and
when it comes to beef only eat grass-fed
beef but cutting out artificial food is
just the first step because the next
thing you have to avoid like the plague
is the water supply
[Music]
thank you
here's the thing America is on a lot of
pharmaceutical drugs painkillers
antidepressants ADHD medication and a
ton more are being used by millions of
people on a daily basis with one of the
most widespread drugs being birth
control and here's the thing about birth
control when someone takes a birth
control pill or any other drug they
usually only end up absorbing 10 of it
the rest of that drug gets peed out
which then gets flushed down the toilet
which then makes its way to water
treatment facilities the only problem is
most birth control pills contain
something called ethanol estradiol a
type of estrogen so all this estrogen
and other terrible chemicals make their
way into the water treatment facilities
and then it gets sent straight back to
your attack problem is most water
treatment facilities don't have the
capabilities to filter out all these
chemicals think about it these
facilities are ancient they're not
Advanced enough to filter all those outs
so these Pharmaceuticals and birth
control pills are not getting filtered
out of your tap water that's why in 2021
seven different water facilities in
Kentucky all had artificial estrogen in
their water supply and you don't even
have to be chucking huge amounts of
estrogens for it to mess you up even a
small amount can cause damage even
contact with this water through your
shower can cause damage it was found
that male fish that swim in water that
contain low levels of artificial
estrogens from birth control ended up
developing feminine traits these male
fish literally start to produce eggs in
their testicles and these horrifying
changes in their hormones were passed
down through the generations which means
a male fish who was exposed to estrogens
would continue to produce Offspring with
deformities whether or not he was still
swimming in the estrogenic water which
is really horrifying and this is the
same water that's coming out of your
sink and shower faucet right now and
we're not just talking about
pharmaceuticals here we haven't even
touched on the microplastics in your
water the lead in your water waterborne
bacteria forever chemicals fluoride and
more
there's an old viral clip of Alex Jones
screaming about they're turning the
frogs gay they're turning the frogs gay
and that's all anyone remembers right
they don't remember the context of that
but long story short there was studies
ran on this you know water in London
what happens is you know you have a
population of women on birth control and
they they urinate and that's the same
water that ultimately ends up in the
drinking water the current water you
know infrastructure doesn't do a good
job of filtering everything out so
there's Trace levels of astrazine across
the board which has been shown to bike
estrogen and all this stuff and so what
Alex is screaming about is in London
they ran studies on these actual frogs
which has been exposed to extremely high
levels of astrazine and the frogs were
they're mating patterns had changed they
turned gay and so that makes you wonder
right as humans who are drinking tap
water on a day in day out basis what
kind of impact does this have on our own
endocrine systems and one would think
that it's extremely estrogenic and
influences male behavior in a way that
probably isn't healthy this is Robert
Oliver by the way he's the founder of
the genius brand which you've probably
seen on Amazon he's a good friend and
overall great guy that has always been
obsessed over optimizing his health now
back to the water supply not even
bottled water is completely safe because
whenever you see purified water on a
bottle that just means they bottled up
tap water to sell it to you except now
it's in the plastic bottle which is full
of something called phthalates which you
guessed it again also mimics the effects
of estrogen in your body so what water
is safe what you want to stick to just
drinking natural spring water that comes
in a glass bottle we looked into it and
these are the brands we recommend
Mountain Valley aquapana and antipathy
sparkling water not sponsored although
it should be these were the only three
spring water brands that we found that
didn't contain fluoride forever
chemicals and other harmful chemicals
but even if you avoid the soy and tap
water completely the attack on
testosterone doesn't end there because
we are just scratching the surface
thank you
[Music]
violates parabens and apes these are
other estrogenic chemicals that are
literally found everywhere they're in
the air in pesticides and in almost
every Cosmetic Skin Care and cleaning
product in existence they're even on
printed receipts but the most serious or
enriched source of bpas are things like
printed receipts that new trendy body
wash you just bought yeah that's full of
artificial estrogens called Apes apes
are the key ingredient that makes soap
sudsy so while you're lathering yourself
up with your body wash these APS which
are full of estrogen get absorbed right
into your skin so basically people are
rubbing estrogen on their skin with
their soap it loves to go through your
skin it doesn't want to wash out in the
water it wants to stay on your skin I
mean the fragrance stays on right so
basically when you you can rub up
against things to get estrogen on you
and you absorb in your skin oh yeah Apes
have been linked to spontaneous abortion
in humans and mice and zebra fresh
embryos that were exposed to Apes
experience genetic changes just two
weeks later so this stuff is potent
there's also phthalates which are found
in children's toys Plastics and perfumes
one study found that pregnant women who
use perfume had 167 percent more
phthalates in their urine than women who
didn't use perfume and even if you avoid
the conventional skin care products you
are still getting exposed BP an
estrogenic chemical used in plastic has
been found in indoor air samples which
includes public offices barber shops and
cars so yeah that new car smell is
actually the sweet sweet smell of
estrogen that new car smell yeah that's
actually estrogen too like that's
plastic but it's the chemical it's
called phthalates they're actually a
little bit attractive to us right like
we like that new car smell because it
tricks our body we think that's estrogen
other chemicals that are disruptive for
testosterone organophosphates those are
things found in all the you know
fertilizer and chemical cleaners out
there things like Mercury like fish
nowadays incredibly High Mercury mercury
levels like if you eat an exclusively
tuna diet you'll likely get mercury
poison we know this is extremely
disruptive for testosterone so it feels
like it's just coming at men from all
angles so what this means is that the US
is a giant Cesspool of toxic estrogens
and there is no slowing this down
[Music]
foreign
countries like China and Europe have
banned estrogenic chemicals meanwhile
America can't seem to get enough that's
because apes phthalates and parabens
make Corporate America go round think
about it like this why would a farmer
waste money on organic farming methods
when they can just spray highly toxic
pesticides on their produce why would
McDonald's put up with stale bread when
they could just sprinkle on an estrogen
called azodiac carbonamide also known as
yoga mat material to make their buns
more soft and as a mega corporation
whose entire livelihood depends on these
chemicals you need to make sure that
nothing will ever get in the way of you
using these chemicals in your products
long term that's why you publish
scientific studies that show just how
safe and harmless these artificial
estrogens can be and in these studies
you make sure to use vague terms like
unlikely just like you did in this study
saying that atrazine a highly estrogenic
pesticide is unlikely to cause breast
cancer you're not saying it doesn't
cause breast cancer you're just saying
that it's unlikely that it will cause
breast cancer see what we did there just
keep it vague and no one will ask
questions
never mind that 12 years later another
study comes out saying that atracy
absolutely does cause breast cancer and
seriously hinders your immune system you
just need to make sure that your Miracle
chemical stays legal for as long as
possible and those scientists that
you're paying to run these studies are
more than happy to do whatever you say
think about it some of them just
graduated college and if you or daddy
government gives them a grant to find
the benefits of estrogenite chemicals on
your behalf they better find some
benefits or they will starve estrogenic
chemicals have made a very still life
feel extremely rich but it's not just
the products that are leading to the
downfall of man it's also the culture
and this is the touchy one
this
foreign
[Music]
level it's kind of being thrown down
men's throats like in high fashion like
dresses are acceptable for for men you
know there's just less and less talk of
what it started with the whole toxic
masculinity thing and just the idea that
being a man in any sort of capacity was
like a negative right caused harm and
damage and so yeah I mean that's it to
me when you have celebrities like
wearing dresses and parading that around
it tends to have an impact it's simple
if you condition men long enough to
believe that it's bad to act like a man
it's gonna have an impact when you
constantly tell men that the way they're
acting is toxic eventually you will wear
them down yeah do you think like this
feminization of men is on purpose like
from from the people that taught like
they want us you know nowadays as I get
older I try not to get into too much of
the conspiratorial stuff like it
certainly feels like that you know it
feels like and if you do zoom out and I
put my conspiracy hat back on a
population of weak men is going to be
dramatically easier to control right
just across the board and so if you can
feminize a population the chances of any
sort of Volt or Revolt or Uprising are
slim to none and so the gun to my head
I'd probably say a lot of it is
intentional I think a lot of it's
probably not like plastics it's just a
you know it has an impact and there's no
incentive for anyone to stop it but it's
really just a cheap material that one
can make as a you know you know the
whole oil industry and all of that and
so I wouldn't label that per se as like
intentional but maybe it is at the end
of the day the net result is much weaker
men across the board yeah I've never
thought
probably unintentional like people just
chasing a dollar or whatever and the
other half happens to align with and
that result happens to align with the
people in power like they want weaker
men so it's just like a convenient thing
correct and it just yeah it seems like
that across the board when you have
media kind of that seems to be a good
rule of thumb when you have media
aligned mainstream media aligned with
one clear and definitive message it's
someone's probably influencing it in
some capacity and we've seen a pretty
consistent talk track on what it means
you know Mass get toxic masculinity the
erosion of gender roles male and female
are equal if we can even Define what
that means estrogen levels are higher
and man men are being feminized the last
thing you want is a feminized male what
you want is the man who's learned to be
a better man alpha male who can also
take care of his children be with his
wife be with his family healthy
testosterone levels he's wearing a dress
wearing a dress doing whippets
when you have low testosterone you won't
be motivated to do anything these days
there's more female students enrolled in
universe overseas than male in the 1950s
70 percent of students were male now
it's only 40 enrollment in sports is
also going down testosterone has some
very interesting effects on the brain
the major mental effect of testosterone
is it makes effort feel good oh that
makes sense well gen Z is statistically
less interested in sex compared to
previous generations but there is good
news amongst all this Doom and Gloom if
you have low testosterone if you suffer
from some of the side effects like
weight gain low muscle mass depression
facial hair loss fatigue you don't have
any sex drive if you suffer from any of
lats there is a simple fix
foreign
[Music]
can you explain like can you actually
naturally or supplementally increase
your testosterone so to be super clear
when you get down to like making a huge
difference in in natural tea levels it
needs to start with lifestyle like I
mentioned earlier obesity is by far the
leading driver of like you know we know
that definitively if you're obese if
you're carrying excess body fat it's
negatively hurting your T levels if
you're not sleeping properly negatively
hurting your T levels if you're over
consuming sugar plastic like all of that
has an impact all right let me just put
kind of like my my key priorities number
one at the top of everything is Sleep
Number Two And this is one that like I
don't deal with or experience but I see
it out there I think a lot of young men
are ruined by their phones and the only
fans and the instant gratification women
and sexualization I think that's a super
real thing that has just a horrendous
impact on testosterone you know they
become these relationships what's the
word when someone like loves a YouTuber
para parasymbiotic or whatever where you
know a lot about the other person or
you're obsessed about them and they
don't know anything about you and
there's a generation of men on that on
Twitch and so I think cutting that out
is huge next is getting some level of
sunlight in your day-to-day life you
know the sun is the thing that's been
supercharging us and powering us from
the beginning of you know humanity and
so don't be afraid to take your shirt
off and and get out there next would be
you know please cut out the Plastics uh
cut out the tap water I'd put those into
the same kind of like extra bucket and
then last but not least you know if
you're in an area with limited sunlight
invest in red light invest in red light
therapy I think that's the the next best
thing getting 15 20 minutes of that a
day it can it can have meaningful impact
on your testosterone levels yeah so
sunlight seems like a very like a very
small thing but you're saying that like
huge yeah it's not big of an impact huge
the vitamin D like just there's all
sorts of different signaling that I'm
not smart enough to explain but I would
say at the end of the day sunlight is
probably you know at the top of that
list right with sleep and all that and
they all feed off each other like if you
get your sunlight first thing in the
morning you're setting your circadian
rhythm in motion you're sleeping better
you know there's stuff with your
cortisol and stress levels and
ultimately that cycle is what's going to
feed healthy hormonal activity and what
I've noticed in my own journey is that
if you cut out all the artificial Foods
in tap water and you just exercise more
that will get you pretty much 80 of the
way there you'll look better and feel
better than 80 of the population just by
doing nuts but as we mentioned
estrogenes are literally everywhere and
short of living off the grid on your own
Homestead you're not going to be able to
escape them chances are you're still
gonna have to interact with products or
air molecules that have toxic stuff in
it so if you want a little bit of a
boost there are certain supplements that
have been shown to increase testosterone
like Andrew huberman has talked about
now for people that aren't getting
prescribed trt but want the increase in
testosterone they're these plant
compounds like Tonga Ali and another one
which is very interesting it's a
Nigerian shrub called fedogia agrestis
and it mimics luteinizing hormone which
is the hormone that comes out the
hypothalamus that stimulates the testes
if you got those in your ovaries if
you've got those to make more
testosterone or estrogen and so those
two herbal supplements together can give
a significant boost in free inactive
testosterone but the problem is the
testosterone supplement space is super
super sketchy
which is why Rob decided to create King
maker King maker is the testosterone
supplement to end all testosterone
supplements that you can pick up by
clicking the link below King maker
contains 12 clinically studied
ingredients it does not have a
proprietary blend so you can actually
see what's in it and what amounts on the
label and the way you can tell is legit
is because of the serving size the
serving size for King maker is five
capsules that's right you have to take
five capsules a day and although that
may sound like a downside if the serving
size was just one or two capsules a day
it would literally be impossible for you
to get the right doses of each
ingredient for it to actually make a
difference and yet that's what every
other fake testosterone supplement does
another way you know kingmaker is legit
is because of the price King maker is
not cheap because Rob uses real
ingredients in the right doses it costs
Rob as much money to make King maker as
well other fake testosterone supplements
are selling for I actually use Ross
products every single day myself and I
love them I can't recommend kingmaker
enough so scroll down click the link
below and buy a bottle for yourself
click the link below to try King maker
now thanks to kingmaker for being the
sponsor of this video
thank you